أوكرانيا المحتلة هي لهب
وإجلاء المدنيين فيها
لا يمكن أن يأتي رحيل روسيا
بالجملة قريبًا بما يكفي لمدينة فرونت لاين أو
هذا الاضطراب الذي دمرته موسكو حيث
سقطت أربعة صواريخ يوم الخميس وحده،
وترك رجال الإنقاذ يخمنون ما
تعنيه الانفجارات المستمرة ورأوا الناس للتو
على طول الطريق هنا يواصلون الحياة
كالمعتاد على الرغم من الغبار في السماء
من حولنا،
قد لا يكون في الواقع منفتحًا
يمكن أن يكون في أي وقت على الإطلاق بصراحة
هذا الغسق يسقط السماء مضاءة في مبارزة
كل ما يمكنهم فعله هنا للبقاء على قيد الحياة هو
اقرأ The Horizon،
ربما يكون بعضها جنوبًا في
المناطق المحتلة عما كانت عليه قبل أسبوع،
شكرًا لك،
ولكن الكثير منها أيضًا قريب جدًا من
الفجر غالبًا ما يكون مزعجًا نسمع طائرة نفاثة تحلق فوقنا
وصوت صرير البناء البطيء للضرر الذي يتحرك نحوك
[موسيقى]
صاروخ  أوه مليون دولار kh-31
قال المسؤولون الأوكرانيون لاحقًا إن الأرض على
بعد 700 ياردة فقط
كنت على الأرض يا صديقي
انفجار آخر يتبع
إما طائرة ومسارات أو نيران مضادة للطائرات
استقرت على شكل حرف z في الهواء
رمز الغزو الروسي
وسرعان ما اختفى  على
الرغم من أن الضرر الذي خلفته، أليس
هذا هو المكان الذي أصابته أو
أخطأته هنا، يمكنك الشعور بمدى
الوحشية الهائلة التي يمكن أن تكون عليها القوة النارية الروسية
وأيضًا مدى العشوائية، لا يزال بإمكاني
شم رائحة المتفجرات هنا وأنت
نوعًا ما على اليسار  أتساءل أين يقع
الهدف العسكري الواضح
في نهاية هذا الطريق، وهي إحدى
البلدات التي قالت روسيا إنها ستقوم
بإخلائها، ونحن على بعد ميل واحد فقط من
مواقع الخطوط الأمامية الروسية هنا، عالم
ممزق حيث تحاول موسكو كبح
جماح أوكرانيا
بشكل جيد بما لا يزيد عن  على بعد 10 أميال في هذا
الاتجاه، توجد أولى البلدات التي
تقول قوات الاحتلال الروسية إنها
ستخليها بسبب
الهجوم المضاد الأوكراني، ولكن انظر
هنا إلى آخر مدينة تسيطر عليها
أوكرانيا وقد تعرضت للضرب التام، ولم يعد هناك سوى عدد قليل من
الأشخاص الذين تركوا هنا  للإخلاء
حيث كان هناك 3000 شخص هناك
200 شخص يحاولون البقاء، تقول رايسا إن اسمي
عالق في هذه المساحات المفتوحة على مصراعيها حيث
يمكن لبنك بعيد أن يغير الحياة فجأة في
لحظة،
انضم إلينا الآن لمناقشة محلل سي إن إن العسكري اللفتنانت
جنرال مارك هيرلينج
آه، شكرًا جزيلاً لك، أحب التحدث إليك
في الصباح لأنك تقدم مثل هذا
التحليل الجيد، أريد أن أسألك أولاً
عن روسيا التي قلصت
يوم النصر الخاص بها والذي لن يبدو
مهمًا إلا أنه كان لدينا شخص ما
لا أعرف من الذي ضربت طائرة بدون طيار
الكرملين ثم بالطبع لديك هذه
الحرب الدائرة في الخلفية والتي
حاولوا إخبار مواطنيهم أنها لم تكن
حربًا في البداية، بل كان من غير القانوني قول
الكلمة، فماذا يفعل  يخبرك عن
هذا العرض حيث توجد دبابة واحدة فقط
على الأرض ثم ترى
الجنود الشباب هناك أيضًا،
سارة، من الرائع التحدث معك أيضًا،
وعندما استيقظت على صور
MayDay Parade، شعرت بالفزع
أعني أنه كان من الرائع رؤية
القليل الذي كانوا يفعلونه في العرض
الذي من المفترض أن يأسر
خيال وتراث
الاتحاد السوفيتي القديم، أعني أنه كان أمرًا
مثيرًا للضحك أن يكون لديهم دبابة واحدة تحمل
العلم السوفيتي  كان لديها
مركبات أخرى لكنها كانت قديمة، وكانت عبارة عن
شاحنات ولم تكن هناك أي
معدات قتالية بخلاف
قاذفات بعض
صواريخها الباليستية، لذا فإن هذا يعطي
مؤشرًا على مدى المشاكل التي تواجهها روسيا
وتعليق نيك بايتون والش
فقط  الآن بخصوص الصواريخ التي لا
تزال تخطئ الهدف لتذهب
إلى المدن حيث تضرب
المباني أه التي يعيش فيها المدنيون ولكن
لا تفعل أي شيء أو يكون لها أي نوع من
التأثير العسكري أه حقًا هو
تعليق على عدم وجود شيء نحن فيه
المكالمة العسكرية تستهدف الاستهداف الدقيق أه
قصة جولتنا الرجال وآذان الصواريخ يعملون
بجد للغاية لإيصال صواريخهم
إلى هدف محدد ويبدو
لي أن روسيا تطلق النار بشكل
تعسفي على مواقع مختلفة،
حقيقة أن نيك كان يقف فيها
الحفرة التي لم تكن قريبة من أي هدف
تخبرني بكل ما أحتاج لمعرفته حول
مدى سوء
إدارة الروس لهذه الحملة، نعم
وبالطبع قد يجادل البعض بأنهم
يضربون عمدًا بعض المناطق التي
يتواجد فيها المدنيون. أريد أن أذكر
شيئًا ما  تحدثت للتو عن
قول الجيش الأوكراني إنه اعترض
23 من أصل 25 صاروخًا روسيًا من طراز كروز، لذا
مرة أخرى، بالنسبة إلى وجهة نظرك، فهم قادرون على إحباط
بعض الهجمات نوعًا ما،
أريد العودة إلى العرض
والشيء الذي سمعناه من رئيس
روسيا  قوة مرتزقة فاغنر أولاً
هددت القوة بوقف القتال
لسحب مقاتليها لأنه
لم يكن هناك ذخيرة كافية، لذا فهي تخبرك
بشيء بسيط عن مكان
وجودهم والآن ينتقد رئيس تلك القوة
الكرملين حتى على إقامة
هذا العرض، إليك ما  قال إنه قال إن
يوم النصر هو انتصار
أجدادنا، وهذا هو الجزء الذي
يجعلك حقًا لم نستحق أن
النصر بمليمتر واحد هل
يخبرك حقًا بما يحدث في أوكرانيا
في هذا الوقت، كما
تعلم يا سيدي لقد كنت  في أعقاب
الدراما التي حدثت بين براغ
الذي هو وزارة الدفاع الروسية
أه غراسيموف الذي يعادل
رئيس هيئة الأركان المشتركة وبوتين، وكانت
هذه مجرد مكيدة سياسية
داخل الكرملين والتي انفجرت
إلى العلن، الروس يرون
هذا  العالم يرى هذا، هناك
هذا الشخص الذي ليس لديه
خلفية عسكرية وهذا تقدم أه إنه
ليس جنديًا ولا يعرف سوى القليل جدًا عن
التجنيد، فقط يرمي اللحوم على
الأوكرانيين ويقتل الكثير من الروس
ثم يعلن أنه لا
يحصل على الدعم، إنه أمر مذهل  بالنسبة لي،
الافتقار إلى الاحترافية وحقيقة
أن روسيا والجنرالات الذين ليسوا
جيدين جدًا حسب تقييمي بناءً على
المحادثات الشخصية وأيضًا ما
أشاهده يسمحون بحدوث ذلك
وأن السيد بوتين يستخدم هذا
كاستراتيجية لـ  من دواعي سروري
دائمًا التحدث
معك بإذكاء الأشياء داخل علامة Chrome المندفعة وأريد فقط أن أذكر أننا
نشاهد صورًا لـ Bak moot هناك
والتي كانت تحت الحصار لعدة
أسابيع حتى الآن